今日から一週間ちょっとこちらのスマホケースで生活してみようと思いますそして
こちら
気になる値段はなんだ380,000円
[音楽]
スマホケースをこちらの教育スマホケースに変えて生活しますと言ってま51週間
巨大な爪方形地で生活してみたんですけども
me
あやめまぁちょっとまあ使用感と言いますがなかなかこのサイズのスマホ掲出を使って
みてどう思ったか
何を感じたかまぁちょっと1週間だけなんですけどこれをつくってみてい色々とは思っ
たことがあったので本当に結構いろんなかと思ったんで
まぁ実際に役に立つこともあれば役に立たないこともあったといろいろ見ていこうと
思いますでどうぞ
行かなきゃバー
すごい
[音楽]
em ん
あっちゃーん
re ん
dj
[音楽]
ええええええ
ad
ana
そうん
me
[音楽]
alejandro
me
9分
[音楽]
ん
uh
bap
もう済ませ
うんアヌううん
ok
想像は何ですかー
[音楽]
ああああああ
ええええええ
第1分けでいかがだったでしょうか本当に大きな利点といえば
ラックしてもすぐ見つかるって言うところの日ですまた基本的に大きい子ちゃまだし
重いし痛いして目立ってしまうまりいいところがなかったそのケースでした
二度と使わねー
[音楽]
me
バッハ
持っ
これ持ち歩くならからおかしいザッハー